les dresseurs le milieu du cirque a
mauvaise réputation
fo veut je moi je trouve ça dommage
pour un cirque qui a une famille
complète à nos rayons pleins d'employés
c'est pas évident de prendre la décision
d'arrêter tout simplement d'avoir des
animaux mais oui les associations
voudraient qu'on arrête tout ça me fais
traiter de tortionnaires d'ordures de
connards qui maltraitent mes animaux moi
on m'a menacé de me mettre le feu à mon
camion parce que mes animaux seraient
mieux mort qu'en captivité alors que ces
animaux là ne peuvent pas être relâchés
dans la nature ils sont nés en captivité
depuis des générations
[Musique]
bienvenue chez bahl août un tigre au nom
d'oursel il vient tout juste d'avoir
deux ans c'est déjà une star
et voici damien son papa comme ils
disent
il est dresseur de tigres depuis plus de
dix années ancien artiste de cirque
il a changé de travail et pour cette île
il construit un parc privé posséder des
tirs en cage en france en 2011 c'est un
acte d'amour militants ou de feu j'ai
voulu savoir pourquoi d'amis et car ni
la soigneuse du parc s'acharnait autant
à garder ses prochains
j'ai commencé comme comme tout le monde
j'ai grandi dans une famille normale et
mon papa m'a notamment toujours emmenés
dans sous un chapiteau un grand cirque
français
c'est là où a commencé l'aventuré en
fait j'avais quatre ans et j'ai dit à
mes parents mais j'aimerais faire ça
plus tard et puis c'est toujours rester
mais il n'y a pas d'école donc du coup
ben j'ai fait un parcours en étant j'ai
commencé comme coiffeur ensuite j'étais
danseur j'étais danseur professionnel
dans les cabarets et tout ça et puis un
jour d'un ami sur mon chemin une
dompteuse qui a accepté de me former
oui mon fils ben oui le fait que en ce
moment on va dire que milieu du cirque
le milieu des dresseurs ont quand même
malheureusement mauvaise réputation et
c'est ce qui a fait qu'aujourd'hui on se
retrouve un peu sans emploi donc pour
moi créer un petit parc pédagogique où
je reçois les jambes pour connaître mon
parcours et mon aventure c'était un
moyen justement de garder mes animaux
tout en respectant la législation
actuelle
pour
au niveau soir tous âges qui m'a
toujours inculqué cette chose-là de se
dire tu prends des animaux tu t'engages
jusqu'à leur mort tu donnes et on les
voit tous les jours
mais voilà en tout cas je parle avec mon
coeur avec mépris vous avez conscience
d'être au coeur d'une bataille de
l'image au cours de ces événements est
ce que doit être la conservation animal
en captivité pas en captivité qu'est ce
que ça représente pour vous au quotidien
d'être au coeur de cette bataille
en fait on se fait vraiment harceler on
a des menaces
moi on m'a menacé de me mettre le feu à
mon camion parce que mes animaux
seraient mieux mort qu'en captivité il
arrivait même que quand j'allais chez le
médecin chez le dentiste ou tout
simplement chez l'ostéopathe je ne
disais pas mon activité
par peur qu'on s'en prenne à moi qu'on
s'en prenne à ma famille d'après vous
qu'est ce qu'ils attendent de vous et
vous livre les auteurs de ces menaces
ils attendent qu'on les place dans des
sanctuaires qu'on les plats chez des
gens qu'on les place dans des refuges
ok ou comment pourquoi de suite dès
qu'on parle de sanctuaires on imagine
des grands espaces on imagine des grands
endroits
excusez moi mais dans un sanctuaire les
animaux sont ni plus ni moins qu en
captivité ils ne peuvent pas parcourir
des kilomètres par eux mêmes ils y sont
toujours nourris par la main de l'homme
ça va prendre des générations pour le ré
apprendre à chasser donc pourquoi est-ce
qu'on irait des données à des gens alors
que moi je passe 15 16 heures par jour à
rester avec eux et à m'en occuper et
avoir de l'amour à voir ce lien entre
comment vous vous êtes sûr que vous
alliez me saoule je ne suis pas
scientifique je n'ai pas fait de grandes
études dans le milieu animal mais je
pense que lorsqu'on se rend compte que
les animaux agissent normalement et
viennent de même vers vous voulez chez
vous faire un bisou ou tout simplement
communiquer pour moi je ne pense pas que
mes animaux ne soient soient malheureux
s'il était malheureux je pense qu'il
refuserait de se nourrir
il serait plutôt agressif avec moi quand
j'entrerai dans la cage parce que
justement ils auraient peur donc
effectivement on a envie de leur donner
plus de place
moi aussi j'aimerais leur faire les
cascades de refaire des rochers et tout
ça ça coûte de l'argent que gagne un
salaire
de travailleur lambda français petit à
petit je mets de l'argent de côté pour
un moment donné arrivé alors donné tout
ça vous savez quand on dit des fois où
quand on entend des gens dire mais vos
enclos son petit vous savez des animaux
passent 17 heures par jour à dormir
voilà le félin n'est pas un grand
sportif as le félin se déplace dans la
nature et parcourt des kilomètres
c'est pour trouver sa nourriture et
parce qu'il sait que derrière lui il
yad'autres tigre qui arrive donc il faut
qu'il se déplace justement pour trouver
d'autres territoires ou tout simplement
ils se déplacent pour repondre pour sa
reproduction en captivité comme ils
n'ont pas besoin de faire tout ça
effectivement il passe beaucoup plus de
temps à dormir
damien du milieu cirque et j'ai pas été
éduqué dans ce milieu là j'ai jamais été
aussi requis étant petit et tout ça et
c'est vrai que j'ai fait comme
énormément de gens sur les réseaux
sociaux avoir des mauvaises images de
mauvais cirque de mauvais traitements et
c'est vrai que j'ai un petit peu
généralisés la chose en disant mon me
voilà dans tous les cirques ça se passe
comme ça et finalement c'est ça que j'ai
apprécié en rencontrant damien c'est que
j'ai pu lui dire que moi j'étais pas du
tout cirque
finalement ma j'ai vu travailler avec
des animaux a pas eu de maltraitance n'y
a pas eu de coups de bâton il n'y a pas
eu de coups de fouet et c'est vraiment
tout en douceur par respect
malheureusement c'est pas partout pareil
mais c'est vrai qu'on a tendance à
généraliser souvent avec les animaux
forcément ils veulent toujours le même
caunes les personnes qui sont contre la
captivité
je n'ai rien contre elle elles ont leur
vision des choses et j'ai ma vision des
choses
j'ai conscience que si on en est là
aujourd'hui était effectivement il ya eu
des erreurs de fait alors attention ça
ne veut pas dire que j excuses la
maltraitance sylvia maltraitance je
n'excuse pas la maltraitance
non moi je pars du principe ou la
captivité n'est pas nocif pour ces
animaux-là partir du moment où elle est
bien faite et ou à partir du moment où
les mots sont respectées je ne vois pas
pourquoi on serait des tortionnaires ou
des ordures plus que une personne lambda
qui a un chien chez l équivalent sa
fille l'a laissé enfermé toute une
journée dans un appartement parce
qu'elle est obligée par sap travailler
pour gagner sa vie
et plutôt que de nous matraquer et de
nous faire passer justement pour des
tortionnaires
venez chez nous venez discuter avec nous
venez vous rendre compte par vous même
parce que justement on a créé ce lieu
parce que je n'ai rien à cacher je n'ai
rien à me reprocher on voit ce qui se
passe dans la semi on voit ce qui se
passe dans les parcs
on voit ce qui se passe quand je donne à
manger je n'ai rien à cacher